S
THOSE FOR A MINUTE OR TWO.
I'VE SUBMITTED MEMORANDA.
>> YOU MAY PROCEED.
>> I'VE SERVED THIS NATION FOR
42 YEARS.
I SPENT YEARS IN COMBAT, AND I
BURIED A LOT OF MY TROOPS WHO
DIED WHILE DEFENDING THIS
COUNTRY.
MY LOYALTY TO THIS NATION, ITS
PEOPLE, AND THE CONSTITUTION
HASN'T CHANGED AND WILL NEVER
CHANGE AS LONG AS I HAVE A
BREATH TO GIVE.
MY LOYALTY IS ABSOLUTE AND I
WILL NOT TURN MY BACK ON THE
FOLLOWING.
WITH RESPECT TO THE CHINESE
CALLS, I ROUTINELY COMMUNICATED
WITH MY COUNTERPART GENERAL LEE
WITH THE KNOWLEDGE AND
COORDINATION OF CIVILIAN
OVERSIGHT.
I AM SPECIFICALLY DIRECTED TO
COMMUNICATE WITH THE CHINESE BY
DEPARTMENT OF DEFENSE GUIDANCE,
THE POLICY DIALOGUE SYSTEM.
THESE MILITARY-TO-MILITARY
COMMUNICATIONS AT THE HIGHEST
LEVEL ARE CRITICAL L TO THE
SECURITY OF THE UNITED STATES IN
ORDER TO DECONFLICT MILITARY
ACTIONS, MANAGE CRISES, AND
PREVENT WAR BETWEEN GREAT POWERS
THAT ARE ARMED WITH THE WORLD'S
MOST DEADLIEST WEAPONS.
THE CALLS ON 30 OCTOBER AND 8
JANUARY WERE COORDINATED BEFORE
AND AFTER WITH SECRETARY ESPER
AND ACTING SECRETARY MILLER'S
STAMPS AND THE INTERAGENCY.
THE SPECIFIC -- WHICH CAUSED US
TO BELIEVE THE CHINESE WERE
WORRIED ABOUT AN ATTACK ON THEM
BY THE UNITED STATES.
I KNOW, I AM CERTAIN THAT
PRESIDENT TRUMP DID NOT INTEND
TO ATTACK THE CHINESE, AND IT IS
MY DIRECTED RESPONSIBILITY AND
IT WAS MY DIRECTED
RESPONSIBILITY BY THE SECRETARY
TO CONVEY THAT INTENT TO THE
CHINESE.
MY TASK AT THAT TIME WAS TO
DE-ESCALATE.
MY MESSAGE AGAIN WAS
CONSISTENT -- STAY CALM, STEADY,
AND DE-ESCALATE.
WE ARE NOT GOING TO ATTACK YOU.
AT SECRETARY OF DEFENSE ESPER'S
DIRECTION, I MADE A CALL TO
GENERAL LEE ON 30 OCTOBER.
EIGHT PEOPLE SAT ON THAT CALL
WITH ME AND I READ OUT THE CALL
WITHIN 30 MINUTES OF THE CALL
ENDING.
ON 31 DECEMBER, THE CHINESE
REQUESTED ANOTHER CALL WITH ME.
THE DEPUTY ASSISTANT SECRETARY
OF DEFENSE FOR ASIA-PACIFIC
POLICY HEMMED COORDINATE MY
CALL, WHICH WAS THEN SCHEDULED
FOR 8 JANUARY, AND HE MADE A
PRELIMINARY CALL ON 6 JANUARY.
11 PEOPLE ATTENDED THAT CALL
WITH ME AND READOUTS OF THIS
CALL WERE DISTRIBUTED TO THE
INTERAGENCY THAT SAME DAY.
SHORTLY AFTER MY CALL ENDED WITH
GENERAL LEE, I PERSONALLY
INFORMED BOTH SECRETARY OF STATE
POMPEO AND WHITE HOUSE CHIEF OF
STAFF MELD MELD DOES ABOUT THE
CALL.
SOON AFTER THAT, I ATTENDED A
MEETING WITH SECRETARY MILLER
AND BRIEFED HIM ON THE CALL.
LATE THEY'RE SAME DAY ON 8
JANUARY, SPEAKER OF THE HOUSE
PELOSI CALLED ME TO INQUIRE
ABOUT THE PRESIDENT'S ABILITY TO
LAUNCH NUCLEAR WEAPONS.
I SOUGHT TO ASSURE HER THAT
NUCLEAR LAUNCH IS GOVERNED BY A
VERY SPECIFIC AND DELIBERATE
PROCESS.
SHE WAS CONCERNED AND MADE
VARIOUS PERSONAL REFERENCES
CHARACTERIZING THE PRESIDENT.
I EXPLAINED TO HER THAT THE
PRESIDENT IS THE SOLE NUCLEAR
LAUNCH AUTHORITY AND HE DOESN'T
LAUNCH THEM ALONE AND THAT I AM
NOT QUALIFIED TO DETERMINE THE
MENTAL HEALTH OF THE PRESIDENT
OF THE UNITED STATES.
THERE ARE PROCESSES, PROTOCOLS,
AND PROCEDURES IN PLACE, AND I
REPEATEDLY ASSURED HER THAT
THERE WAS NO CHANCE OF AN
ILLEGAL, UNAUTHORIZED, OR
ACCIDENTAL LAUNCH.
BY PRESIDENTIAL DIRECTIVE AND
SECRETARY OF DEFENSE DIRECTIVE,
THE CHAIRMAN IS PART OF THE
PROCESS TO ENSURE THE PRESIDENT
IS FULLY INFORMED ON DETERMINING
THE USE OF THE WORLD'S DEADLIEST
WEAPONS.
BY LAW I AM NOT IN THE CHAIN OF
COMMAND AND I KNOW THAT.
HOWEVER, BY PRESIDENTIAL
DIRECTIVE AND DOD INSTRUCTION, I
AM IN THE CHAIN OF COMMUNICATION
TO FULFILLY LEGAL STATUTORY ROLE
AS THE PRESIDENT'S PRIMARY
MILITARY ADVISER.
AFTER THE SPEAKER PELOSI CALL I
CONVENED A SHORT MEETING IN MY
OFFICE WITH KEY MEMBERS OF MY
STAFF TO REFRESH ALL OF US ON
THE PROCEDURES WHICH WE
DAILY AT THAT LEVEL.
I INFORMED MILLER OF SPEAKER
PELOSI'S PHONE CALL.
AT NO TIME WAS I ATTEMPTING TO
CHANGE OR INFLUENCE THE PROCESS,
USURP AUTHORITY, OR INSERT
MYSELF IN THE CHAIN OF COMMAND.
BUT I AM EXPECTED, I AM REQUIRED
TO GIVE MY ADVICE AND ENSURE
THAT THE PRESIDENT IS FULLY
INFORMED ON MILITARY MATTERS.
I AM SUBMITTING FOR THE RECORD A
MORE DETAILED AND UNCLASSIFIED
MEMORANDUM I BELIEVE YOU HAVE,
ALTHOUGH LATE.
I'D BE HAPPY TO TALK ABOUT THE
INTELLIGENCE THAT DROECH THESE
CALLS.
I'M HAPPY TO MAKE AVAILABLE AN
EMAIL, PHONE LOGS, MEMORANDA,
WITNESSES OR ANYTHING ELSE YOU
NEED TO UNDERSTAND THESE EVENTS.
MY OATH IS TO SUPPORT THE
CONSTITUTION OF THE UNITED
STATES OF AMERICA AGAINST ALL
ENEMIES FOREIGN AND DOMESTIC.
AND I WILL NEVER TURN MY BACK ON
THAT OATH.
I FIRMLY BELIEVE IN CIVILIAN
CONTROL OF THE MILITARY AS A
BEDROCK PRINCIPLE ESSENTIAL TO
THE HEAL